And so they're off to pleasure island
dark place and uh,
the coachman opens the gates and lets
the delinquents into pleasure island and
they basically have a riot.
And this is pleasure island here.
It's full of amusement park rides.
And you know,
one of the things that's kind of
interesting about horror movies,
I'm sure you've noticed this,
is that they're often sat at amusement
parks and clowns are often characters of
horror.
We'll leave the clowns aside for now.
But the amusement park thing that's
pretty interesting.
It's like why in the world with an
amusement park,
he,
a place of horror.
And the first question might be,
well,
have you ever been to an amusement park?
Because there is something about them
that's really.
They have a dark side,
clear,
dark side.
And part of it is that people with
nothing better to do or spending money
stupidly.
And they're being fleeced by the people
who operate the the amusement park,
you know,
and they have,
let's say,
a stereotypically dark reputation and
they're moving around all the time,
which is also something that psychopaths
do and all they're doing is moving from
community to community and taking the
money from the rubes fundamentally.
And so the amusement park,
well if you walk through an amusement
park without sort of thing in mind,
maybe that's also coloring your vision
of course,
but it's something that you could see
very immediately.
So there's something about them that's
sort of deeply sad,
but there's also that under,
there's an underlying horror that
characterizes them that it's easy for
horror movie or horror novel writers to
immediately expand upon.
And there's something about it that,
that makes sense to people.
So it's too easy.
Maybe that's.
And it's also all short term
gratification.
That's the other thing.
So you spend your money very rapidly and
it's gone.
Yep.
Yes,
exactly.
Well,
that's the impulsive element that the
comment was,
it's a celebration of,
of meanings divorced from reality.
Yeah.
That's.
Well,
it's also outside of reality,
right?
That's why it's on an island,
it's a separate universe and it's a
universe where nothing that's happening
is connected to anything outside and
you're spending your hard earned money,
let's say,
but it isn't that much.
It's certainly not an investment.
It's not that much different than
burning it what is because of course you
get some pleasure out of it,
but.
But it isn't going with their everyday
is probably not the wisest move that you
could make.
So the animators do a good job of,
of while I'm presenting the,
what would you call it,
the in hedonism,
I guess I would say of a place like
that.
This is a place where you're going to
have fun.
That's what it's for.